The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Everyone,
welcome back
to Poker Theory and Analytics.
We're very lucky today to have a
guest speaker, Matt Hawrilenko.
Matt's background is
really interesting.
He was a Princeton grad who
went to work for a Cisco
International group
for a couple of years,
and then he left to become
a professional poker
player full time.
He was considered one of the
best limit hold'em players
in the world in addition to
winning a World Series of Poker
bracelet.
More recently he
retired from poker
and is focusing on
clinical psychology
where he studies in
Boston at both Clark
University and Harvard.
So with that, I'll pass it
along to Matt Hawrilenko.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT HAWRILENKO: OK.
Hey.
So I'm super excited
to be here today.
And as I understand, I've been
told that I'm your second game
theory guy.
And I guess Bill, Bill
Chen, one of my best friends
in poker who I've
done a lot of work
with came in and talked
to you guys last week.
I'm going to take a
slightly different angle
than Bill did last week.
So first I kind of
just want to get
a sense of who's in the room.
So my presumption
is that there might
be sort of like widely
varying levels of experience
with game theory.
So if you just don't mind
kind of helping me out,
so who here has seen a
game theory game before,
like prisoner's dilemma,
something like that?
OK.
So most of us.
Who here has actually solved
a couple of game theory games,
like with pen and paper,
matrix algebra, whatever?
OK.
About half.
Has anyone actually taken
a game theory class?
All right.
Great.
So I'm kind of
hoping this talk is
sort of going to be equally
useful for everyone,
but we'll find out.
So Bill talked to you guys
about Cepheus last week.
I'm going to talk about
something a little different
than Bill usually talks about.
So I'm going to try to talk
about how to play good poker.
And so if we think of this
problem of playing good poker
is this big game space.
There are two ways that
people generally approach it
in that they'll take a
read-based approach, which
is pretty much what
everybody does, right?
You try to figure out
what the other guy has,
what he might have,
and go from there.
You can take a game
theoretic approach.
So I'm going to try
today discriminate
a little bit between
these two approaches,
and I'm going to talk about
why, whatever level of poker
you're at, game theory is
something they can complement
your game or just be your game.
For me it is my game.
And broadly speaking,
the reason that I
think game theory is
particularly useful for poker
goes something like this.
So one of the things that
I love to do off the table,
I do jujitsu.
Which if you guys
don't know what
that is, it's kind of like
wrestling where you're trying
to choke the guy or hyperextend
their arm or something
like that.
And when you start
out doing jujitsu,
you start out as a white belt,
and you're competing against,
rolling with other white belts.
And you can learn this
whole repertoire of moves.
And tons of stuff works
against white belts, right?
Like, whatever you
do, it's probably
going to work
against white belts.
As you get better
or as you start
going against better
competition-- blue belts,
purple, brown,
black belts-- a lot
of the moves that worked against
white belts don't work anymore.
Not only do they
not work, they can
tend to get you in
quite a lot of trouble.
So I think that the
best way to approach
this game is from
day one, you're not
training to be white belts.
You're training to be
black belts, right?
You want to learn the moves
that work all the way along
against the best competition.
And I think it's sort of the
same way with poker, right?
So if you think about it,
if you play in a home game
or whatever with a
bunch of buddies,
you might have one strategy
that works fairly well, right?
Maybe you play really tight, you
bet a lot with your best hands,
and you don't bluff that much.
And this works really
well because most people
don't really have a
sense of what's what,
of the strength of hands.
They overvalue their hands.
So you take that
strategy to the Bellagio
and you play in even mid limit
games with reasonable players,
and all of a sudden you're
starting to get eaten alive.
So I'm going to talk about how
game theory can sort of help
you avoid this and help you
be strong and grow stronger
all the way along.
So now if we think
about game theory,
really there are two audiences
that we could be speaking to,
right?
So Bill came in last
week and he talked
about Cepheus, this algorithm
that solved my best game.
And, well, that is sad for me.
I'm not going to spend a lot
of time dwelling on that here.
Rather I'm going to talk
about what humans can do,
how humans can apply game theory
at the table to their game.
And this is for a
couple of reasons,
but maybe the bigger one is
I've had a fair bit of math,
but I can't solve the kinds of
problems that Bill can solve.
But my work has sort of
been on taking game theory,
taking these concepts,
and really using them
in a practical sense.
So that's what I want
to talk about today.
So if we're thinking
about this there
are, again, a couple
angles we could take.
We could talk about it from
a theoretic perspective.
We could solve a lot of games.
We could solve
dynamical systems,
and see how that works.
Or we could talk
about it in practice.
What does game theory tell me?
How does it tell me I should
think about this situation?
Of course, I think
the theory practice
dichotomy is a false economy.
So what I want to do is I want
to spend a little bit a time
solving some really, really
simple toy games, two toy
games.
And I want to sort of use
that to bridge the theory
and practice gap.
So I want to take a
couple of toy games
and then apply them to a real
hand of high stakes poker
I played.
So I'm going to use that
hand to motivate how we might
apply some of these ideas.
So then finally at
the end of the day,
we can come up
with a list, right?
We can think of a
rule-based strategy.
That's something that learning
from Cepheus might give you.
It might tell you what to do
in every specific situation.
But that's really hard.
Poker's really big.
You can't really
remember all of that.
So the thing that I really hope
you guys take away from my talk
today is some training
principles, some ways
to think about the game which,
as you finish this class
I guess in a couple of days and
move on throughout your poker
careers, whatever
those might be,
some tools that can
sort of help you
continue working on your game.
So let's just get going.
So sometimes in poker we get
put in really tough spots,
and it can start to
feel like we're trying
to guess our way out of them.
Varying degrees of guess
our way out of them.
Sometimes we might be sort
of making educated guesses,
sometimes they might
be less educated.
But what do we do?
What do you do in that really
tough spot where you just
don't know what's going on?
So this happened to me a
couple of years ago in-- this
happens to me all the time.
But this happened to me a couple
of years ago in a World Series
tournament that I played.
We were deep.
We were in the money.
And the one thing I want
you guys to keep in mind
here is I'm playing this
hand against a player who
is just much better than me.
So that sucks.
On the other hand, I have aces.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to take you really
briefly through the hand and
let you know how I was thinking
about it, and we'll
kind of look at it
from a couple perspectives.
So we're both
really, really deep.
The blinds are 12 and
24,000 with a $3,000 ante,
and we're six handed.
So I raise two off
the button with aces.
I raise a little bit, he calls.
Flop comes, king, jack, eight.
He checks, I bet, he calls.
It turns a five.
He checks, I bet
about 2/3 of the pot.
He calls.
And then the river's a king.
And then he reaches for
his chips, and I feel good.
I'm like, oh, money.
And then he bets just about
$1.1 million to a $700,000 pot.
And now I'm like, I don't know.
I have no idea.
So he's betting I'm happy.
I see the amount.
I'm confused.
So here's how the hand looks.
So I'm sitting
there and I'm just
trying to get a
sense of his range,
and I'm thinking, like,
bet of 1.5 times the pot.
What does that mean?
What kind of hands is
he betting so much with?
Why isn't he putting me all in?
Why is it a little below all in?
Is he trying to entice me?
Or maybe he's trying to
save $300,000 if I fold.
All these thoughts are
going through my head.
So before we talk about what
I did, I'm actually curious.
Are you guys happy with
the information I gave you?
Is there more information
that you want?
What do you want to know?
AUDIENCE: How big is the
gap between getting out
now and getting out next?
MATT HAWRILENKO:
Ooh, good question.
So let's just say it's
pretty linear at this point.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MATT HAWRILENKO: Anything
else you want to know?
Oh, you want to know lots.
What do you want to know?
AUDIENCE: Has he
shown down big bluffs?
MATT HAWRILENKO: Has he
Good question, we've played
with him a little bit,
and I don't actually recall.
But he's certainly capable
of showing down big bluffs.
I fancied myself a pretty
good player at the time,
and he is someone that
I would consider one
of the top players in the game.
Anything else?
Anyone else?
Any questions?
Right.
And so it sounds
like what you're
trying to do is you're
trying to get a sense of,
what is his range?
Does he have a lot of
bluffs in this spot?
Does he have any
And I think that's how
pretty much most of us
tend to approach the game.
It's most natural way
to approach the game.
Is he bluffing, isn't he?
Does he have too
many bluffs here?
Out of curiosity,
does anyone want
to stare him down for tells?
Nobody wants to stare him down.
You might want to
stare him down.
This guy wants to
[LAUGHTER]
This guy definitely
wants to stare him down.
This guy wants to stare
him down for sure.
By the way, if you get
this look, good work.
It means you've done your job.
It's uncomfortable.
But I want to tell you exactly
what he's thinking right now.
What he's thinking goes
something kind of like this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
But it can feel
like this, right?
Tough players can put us in
spots where we're just thinking
about monkeys clashing symbols.
And when we don't
have a repertoire,
I think, that we start
reading really heavily
into small signals, right?
We're trying to
figure something out.
So generally speaking,
my view, there
are some tells that are OK.
There are some tells that kind
of work against weak players
and less and less
against better players.
But these are small signals
in a whole lot of noise.
Very small signal in a
very noisy environment.
Certainly not something to
build a career on, right?
In the big games,
you rarely see tells.
You just don't see them enough
for that to be profitable.
But actually some people
do build careers on them.
So FBI interrogators
build careers
on these kinds of tells.
So how do they do?
Well, we actually have
some data in that spot.
There have been a
whole series of studies
where basically the paradigm
is you bring in some FBI
interrogators, and then you
bring in some random people
from the street.
And you have them watch
someone interview a person.
And then at the end of the
day you have to figure out,
is this person telling the
truth, or is this person lying?
How do you think they do?
AUDIENCE: Same.
MATT HAWRILENKO: Same?
Yeah.
Same in every category.
So everyone is basically
chance, or maybe like 53%.
So they do exactly the
same as the random people
off the street, these
body language experts,
except for one difference.
The one difference is they
are way more confident
that they are right, OK?
So you ask them their
level of confidence,
and most people are
like, eh, I don't know.
Like 50%.
The interrogators are, like,
90% sure that they're right.
So they're not alone, right?
So I don't know if you guys have
heard of self-assessment bias.
It's one of my favorite biases.
So one more study.
So it was sort of motivated by
this old study of GE engineers.
It's like 30 years ago.
And what they do is they ask,
OK, of all the engineers at GE,
where do you rank?
What is your percentile
rank of everyone?
And they ask basically everyone.
So you would think
these being engineers,
engineers being math
guys, that they have
a good sense of percentiles.
You'd think that they
might get this right.
The average engineer
ranks themself right
about at the 80th percentile.
Of all the people
they asked-- they
asked, like, maybe a hundred
of them-- of all the people
they asked, two ranked
themselves as below average.
That is my favorite data
point from this study.
Two ranked themselves
as below average.
Should be about half.
And they're not
alone too, right?
So poker players also famous
for their self-assessment bias.
And one of the things
that I think sort of
feeds into this,
at the beginning
of Rounders-- I haven't seen
this movie for, like, five
years.
I don't know if you
guys have seen Rounders.
But at the beginning
of Rounders,
Matt Damon's character
quotes this poker book.
It's one of my all
time favorite quotes
from a poker movie which,
I guess, isn't saying much.
But gives this
quote, "Few players
can remember the big
pots they've won,
but every player can remember
with remarkable accuracy
the outstanding tough
beats of their career."
And I think it's these
sort of memory biases
that feed into our
self-assessment bias, right?
So you walk into the Bellagio,
you see a table of all pros.
There has to be self-assessment
bias here, right?
There has to be.
So don't be that person.
Let me circle back to my point.
I'm going to tell you
about my favorite poker
hand of all time.
Of every hand I've
ever played, this
is my favorite for
a number of reasons.
So I'm playing a tournament
in the World Series.
This is a big tournament.
And we're on the
exact money bubble.
And what that means is that
the next person to bust
out gets nothing.
Everyone else is guaranteed
something, couple dozen bucks.
I don't know.
So I'm sitting there, and
there's this guy at my table
who, as we approach
the money bubble,
he's so excited to be there.
It's his first World
Series tournament,
he's about to make the money.
He's calling his girlfriend
and his buddies every hour
telling them, yeah, I think
we're almost in the money.
He's so excited.
And then it gets
to the point where,
like, 40 minutes before
the bubble, he just leaves.
He doesn't want to play a hand.
He just leaves the table so
he doesn't have to bust out.
So he comes back.
And it's now the actual bubble.
He's to my direct left.
I'm in the small blind,
he's in the big blind,
and it folds around to me.
And at this point, I
feel like there are just
dollar signs in my eyes, right?
I'm so excited.
So I look down and I
see four deuce off suit.
And we both have
medium stacks, but I
have this hell of a read on
this guy, so I shove all in.
He says, I knew you
were going to do that.
I call blind.
He calls without
looking at his cards
because he knew I was
going to shove in.
It's like the strongest
[INAUDIBLE] I've ever had.
He flips over his hand.
He has nine deuce off the suit.
He has me dominated
with a terrible hand.
Let's think about this.
How terrible does
my read have to be?
How far off does it have to be?
What has to happen here
for him to call with nine
deuce off suit.
Not only does he
have to not care
about bursting out,
busting out on the bubble.
He has to not care so
much that he won't even
look at his cards.
If he looks at his
hand, he has to fold.
So he proceeds to win the hand.
And they count us down, and
he has me literally covered
by one or two chips.
And I walk away thinking
I have to go home.
We rent a math house
every year out in Vegas.
Me and Bill Chen,
Jerrod Ankenman,
Mike who's sitting
right over there,
and a bunch of other of us.
I have to go home and I
have to tell these guys what
just-- Kenny, who's
right here-- I
have to tell these guys
what just happened,
and I still don't
hear the end of it.
So what does this mean?
So I realize the
beginning of this talk
sounds a little bit like
a commercial for like,
just be humble.
Don't be an idiot.
But I think it's a
little more than that.
Here's the takeaway.
Any time you try to divine
your opponent's strategy,
she can do the same
thing back to you.
And this happens in
really obvious ways,
like when my super tight guy
all of a sudden doesn't care.
But it also happens
in subtle ways, right?
So a lot of times we
think about pot odds.
So you might be
sitting there thinking,
OK, I'm getting two to one.
Do I have the best hand here
at least one in three times?
Very natural way
to think, right?
But now you're kind
of trying to do magic.
That's one of my favorite
quotes of all time,
by the way, from Harry Potter.
And the trouble is, the
other side can do magic too.
I'm trying to figure out
what their distribution is
and respond to it.
They're trying to
figure out what
I think their distribution
is and shape it around that.
And all of a sudden, we're
playing this leveling game.
And we're both kind of
trying to do magic, right?
So in the hand that I showed
you guys in the beginning,
I could be sitting
there and trying
to figure out exactly what
my opponent's range is
when she bets one and
a half times the pot.
I can try to figure out why
he's not putting me all in.
I can try to figure out a
million other little things
that are going to
help me get a little
more sense of this range,
but I'm trying to do magic.
And I think that's kind of our
go to move when we don't really
have a repertoire, right?
And this is going to happen
more and more-- well,
it happens with
really bad players,
bu that's OK-- but it's
going to happen more
and more with good players.
They'll take you
to a place where
they have this paved road.
They've been there before.
They take people to
these weird places.
And you haven't.
And what do you do?
So what I would say
is forget their hand.
Forget their range.
Don't think about it.
So one of my favorite people
in the world, Jerrod Ankenman,
he's the one who
wrote Bill's book
and let Bill put his
name on it, by the way.
He has this quote, "If I
truly played optimally,
I could write down
my entire strategy
on a piece of
paper, what I would
do in every single situation,
and I could give it to you
and you couldn't beat me."
That's what we're
trying to do here.
So how do we get there?
Well, heads-up limit hold'em
turns out to be a pretty big
game.
It has about a
quintillion game states,
and that's the
smallest poker game
that we really play for money.
So we can do a
couple things, right?
We can try to do some, like,
sweet programming like the team
out in Alberta did.
And that's great.
You know, for example,
humans play chess, right?
And computers now crush them,
but human learning is really
strongly aided by computers.
But you can't memorize
every position.
You can't memorize every line.
You have to know what's
going on underneath the hood.
And these algorithms, these
programs like Cepheus, they
will give you the strategy.
They will not tell you why.
And as humans, we need to
start to understand why
if we have any hope of carrying
these strategies with us
and actually playing
them in real life.
So they're a black box, right?
So we can solve the games.
But solving the games does
not get us out of the woods.
So if we want to wrap our
puny human minds around it,
we have to be a
little more clever.
So we're going to look at
a couple of toy games here,
really simple ones
that can start
to help us wrap our
minds around how
to behave in these situations.
So the first one is
a clairvoyance game.
And a clairvoyance
game is basically
when either one or both players
have complete game state
information.
So what would you do
if you lived in a world
where you always knew
your opponent's hand
and he knew that you knew?
That's the idea of
a clairvoyance game.
So we're going to look at a game
called Coin Flip Clairvoyance.
And the game goes like this.
You can and should play
it for money by the way.
So each player antes a dollar.
There are two players.
And then you flip a coin.
If it's heads, you win.
If it's tails,
your opponent wins.
However, there's a
round of betting.
Only you see the
coin after the flip.
Then you can bet or check.
So you choose to bet
a dollar or check,
and your opponent
can only check.
If you check, they have
to flip over hand or call.
If you bet, they either have
to call a dollar or fold, OK?
So you know if you win or not.
Your opponent doesn't know
if they'll win a showdown.
That's the idea of this game.
Make sense?
Yeah OK, easy game.
So how do we play?
So scenario one.
Flip the coin.
It's heads.
What do we do?
AUDIENCE: Bet.
MATT HAWRILENKO: Bet.
OK.
Scenario two.
It's tails.
What do we do?
So there are two main questions.
How often should
your opponent call,
and how often should you bluff?
So how do we solve this?
What we want to do
is we want to call
enough to make your opponent
indifferent to bluffing
or giving up.
That's what your
opponent should be doing.
So to do that,
we're going to set
the expectation of bluffing
equal to the expectation
of giving up.
So the expectation of
bluffing is just this, right?
It's the pot times
the amount they fold,
which is one minus the
proportion of the times
they called, right?
That's how much you
win when you bluff.
So now how much do
you lose when you
bluff and get caught, right?
It's the amount
you bluff, which is
going to be one unit, times
the amount you get called.
So we can just sort of do
a little simple algebra,
and it'll reduce to-- you
should be calling p over p
plus 1 of the time, where
p is the pot, right?
So if the pot is two units
and you're bluffing one unit,
we should be calling with a
proportion of two over three.
2/3 of the time with our kings.
That is how we make the
opponent indifferent to bluffing
or giving up.
OK?
So a couple of things to note
about this before we push on.
So what happens here
as the pot gets bigger?
Do you call more or less?
AUDIENCE: More
MATT HAWRILENKO: More.
Yeah/ So as the pot gets bigger,
this asymptotes to 1 which
makes sense, right?
Most of the value's
already in the pot.
So there's more money in there.
You have to protect against
being bluffed at more.
Totally intuitive
with poker, right?
So how often do you bluff?
Well, you want to set
the expected value
of calling equal to the
expected value of folding.
So the expected
value of calling here
is just-- we're going to use the
ratio of bluffs to value bets
rather than a percentage.
It just works out nicer.
So the ratio of bluffs to
value bets, so how frequently
are you bluffing,
times the pot plus one
because that is what
they win when they call.
So bluffs value that times
the pot plus the unit
that you bluff.
And then what do they lose
when they call in their wrong?
They lose the amount
you bet, so that's
going to be one unit,
the value you bet.
So you're going
to bluff p plus 1.
So you're going to bluff 1
over p plus 1 of the time.
So now what happens here?
So as the pot gets bigger,
what are you doing?
Bluffing more or less?
AUDIENCE: Less.
MATT HAWRILENKO: Less.
Yeah.
Is that counterintuitive?
AUDIENCE: No.
MATT HAWRILENKO: Is it?
I don't know.
It was counterintuitive to me
because I'm like, oh, there's
more money in the pot.
But what it means is there's
more money in the pot,
so I don't really need to bluff
very frequently to make sure
I get value, because
the values in there,
and my opponent is
calling more of the time.
So the bigger the pot is, the
more my opponent calls, right?
And what I'm doing
essentially is
I'm bluffing so I can get value
from the time that I'm winning.
Yeah?
OK.
So we can actually
generalize this too, right?
So we can generalize it to
no limit games pretty simply.
So we've sort of flipped
things around here.
So here the pot is 1 and s
is the proportion of the pot
that you bet, so you're
going to be calling 1 over 1
plus s, right?
So if the pot is two
units, s is one unit,
so s would be 0.5, right?
1 plus 0.5 is one half.
And you'd be bluffing
s over 1 plus s, right?
So you're going to be calling
1 minus the bluff ratio.
Sometimes we call the
bluff ratio alpha.
1 minus alpha.
But we can actually calculate
a value for this game
and for all toy games.
So Bowling and their team
with Cepheus they calculated
the value of having the
button in limit hold'em.
We always kind of
knew it was good,
but they calculated precisely
just how good it was.
And if you're looking for a
job at a place like [? Sig ?]
or somewhere else in
finance, you actually
probably should just
calculate the value of this,
because you're
going to be getting
interview questions like this.
So again, what we're taking
here is the larger amount
your opponent gets, the less
frequently you have to call.
Right?
The more frequently
your opponent bluffs,
the more frequently she
has to value that, right?
So as a bluffing
region gets larger,
the value betting region
has to get larger with it.
So in a coin flip game
it doesn't make sense
to think of regions, but
in poker it's going to.
So a question I get
here a lot is, what
if it's not a repeated game?
What if you're playing
it just this one time?
Or what if you're at
a table with a player
that you'll never
play with again?
How do you play that?
And the answer is that
it's a repeated game.
So I have a feeling this will
be intuitive for you guys,
so I'll do it quickly.
But I want you to
imagine a scenario
where you're going to play
the Coin Flip Clairvoyance
game a thousand times
against different players.
So against a thousand
different players, right?
And suppose you
take the position,
since my opponents can't
learn from my past,
I'm going to bluff
100% of the time.
So what's actually
happening here?
You can sort of think of each
opponent as a random sampling
from the distribution
of possible strategies
that are out there for the
Coin Flip Clairvoyance game.
So some of them will fold too
much, and you will own them.
And then some of them
will call too much,
and they will own you if you're
bluffing all of the time,
right?
So even if you haven't
seen this person before,
even if it's your first
hand of poker against them,
it is a repeated game, OK?
So get that, it's not a repeated
game notion out of your heads.
It's bad for business.
So taking like a
half a step back,
what have we learned
about this so far?
OK.
So the Coin Flip Clairvoyance
game, it's not about just value
betting or just bluffing.
It's about the
combination of the two.
We're also trying to maximize
the value of our entire set
of hands, right?
Because what happens?
So suppose our
strategy is, we're
going to bet every
time we have heads,
we're never going to
bet when we have tails?
What's our opponent going to do?
AUDIENCE: Fold to every bet.
MATT HAWRILENKO: They're
going to fold to every bet.
Yeah, exactly.
So we sort of can
calculate this ratio
where now they don't do so
well if they fold to every bet.
And so what's cool about this
is the math in this game is
very simple, right?
It's not hard.
But it buys you a lot.
It buys you a lot of
intuition about poker.
Some really useful concepts.
So I want to move on.
This is probably my favorite
of all the toy games,
and there are actually a
million versions of it.
We're going to do
the simplest one
because I think it sort of
gets everything that you
need to know, more or less.
So this is an ace,
king, and queen game.
It's an incomplete
information game.
So each player antes $1
and is dealt one card.
So if I get delta
ace, my opponent
only has the king or the queen.
They can't also have an ace.
So then you can check of
bet and your opponent,
just like the Coin
Flip Clairvoyance game,
can only check or call or fold.
They can't bet if you check.
So this is going to be our
first mapping, our only mapping,
of a toy game that
resembles real poker, right?
Now we have a real range.
Again, I think that you
probably can and should
play this game for money.
I think there's a real
difference between what we're
about to do, which is
solve it and sort of get it
intuitively, and actually
get it experientially.
So go forth and gamble.
But what do we do?
So case one.
So you get the ace.
Are you going to check or bet?
AUDIENCE: Bet.
MATT HAWRILENKO:
You're going to bet.
Yeah.
Now your opponent bets
and you have an ace.
What are you going to do?
AUDIENCE: Call.
MATT HAWRILENKO:
You're going to call.
All right, good.
And now your opponent
bets, and you have a queen.
What are you going to do?
AUDIENCE: Fold.
MATT HAWRILENKO: Yeah.
Hey, yeah.
OK.
So it seems trivial, right?
These first three cases
seem really trivial.
But an important
thing to note is
that they are
dominant strategies
or dominated strategies.
So a dominated strategy in
game theory, for example,
calling with a queen
here would be dominated.
A dominated strategy is
one where the decision has
equal or lesser-- strictly
equal or lesser value
to another decision.
If I call with a
queen, I cannot win.
I just lose money.
That has strictly lesser
value than folding, OK?
So dominated strategies,
important concept.
So how about this one.
You have a king.
Check or bet?
AUDIENCE: Check.
AUDIENCE: Check
MATT HAWRILENKO: Check.
AUDIENCE: Split.
MATT HAWRILENKO: Split?
OK.
All right, well, I actually
want to see where everyone's in.
So we're going to
have three options.
Who wants to check?
All right, who wants
to bet all the time?
Who wants to bet sometimes?
OK.
See, I tricked you.
This is also a
dominated strategy.
So what happens if you
have a king and you bet?
What is your opponent
going to do with an ace?
AUDIENCE: He's either
going to call with an ace
or fold with a queen.
MATT HAWRILENKO: Exactly.
Your opponent-- because
the ace and the queen,
dominant strategies, right?
Your opponents always
calling with an ace,
always folding a queen.
So betting with a king here
would be a dominated strategy.
Strictly dominated by checking.
How about here?
Now we have a queen.
What do we want to do?
Check or bet?
AUDIENCE: Bet.
MATT HAWRILENKO:
Check, bet, exactly.
We want to bet some of the time.
Right?
And we'll go
through [INAUDIBLE].
And now we have a king
and our opponent bets.
What do we want to do?
AUDIENCE: Mix.
MATT HAWRILENKO: Mix.
Good.
You got the idea.
Does anyone have any guess as
to how the mix might break down?
AUDIENCE: Depends
on his proportion
of bluffing with the queen.
MATT HAWRILENKO: OK.
But suppose we're
trying to solve it.
So it depends on his proportions
bluffing with the queen.
Exactly.
And let's get tighter.
How do we solve it, right?
So if we have a
king, our opponent
has an ace half the time and
has a queen half the time.
They're going to bet all
the time with the ace
and sometimes with the queen.
Turns out in this
game that it's going
to be about the same
or exactly the same.
She should be calling
1 over 1 plus s, s
being the fraction of the pot.
So you should be calling with
2/3 of hands that beat a bluff.
So the hands that beat a bluff
are aces and kings, not queens,
right?
So if we're thinking about
it this way, before-- eh, no.
I'll show this first.
So aces are going to represent
50% of the hands that
beat a bluff, right?
Because you're
going to have aces
50% of the time and
kings 50% of the time.
So calling with aces seems
better than calling with kings.
So we're going to call
with all of our aces.
So now we're up to half, but
we need to get to 2/3, right?
We want to be calling 2/3 of the
time, kind of per our formula.
So we're calling
with all of our aces,
and then a third of
our kings times having
a king half the time,
that's another sixth, right?
So all of our aces and
a third of our kings.
So how is thinking
about it this way
different from thinking
about it using pot odds?
So for pot odds we're
trying to figure out,
what does this person
have in this situation?
So I'm sitting here with
a king with pot odds,
and I'm thinking, am I ahead at
least a third of the time here?
I don't know exactly.
But I know that
I can try to make
my opponent indifferent
to bluffing or calling.
So I'm thinking
about what I'm doing
with my whole range of hands.
So yeah, OK.
So these are the
two observations
we had from the Coin
Flip Clairvoyance game.
So adding one.
One thing that we're noting here
with the ace, king, and queen
game, what are we doing?
We're sort of implicitly mapping
three different types of hands.
Value hands, bluff
catchers, and bluffs.
And the big thing
here is your strategy
for what you do with one
hand determines your strategy
for other hands, all right?
I'm definitely
calling with the aces,
so I need to call with
some kings, right?
I'm definitely
betting all my aces,
so I need to bluff with the
lowest-- like, the worst
part of my distribution, right?
That's the part that's
going to gain the most.
So a more subtle thing that
I think is super important
and is going to play into sort
of the last half of this talk
is if I am playing a hand
differently from you,
I should do different
things with other hands
than you should.
Say for whatever reason I'm
only betting half of my aces
but I'm still betting
a third of my kings.
Whoops.
Now I'm out of whack, right?
Now I'm out of balance, and I'm
going to lose more in this game
by being out of balance.
So your strategy for one
hand determines your strategy
for other hands.
That's the whole key here, OK?
So to sort of summarize
what we've done so far
is the Temple of Apollo.
This is where I'd like you
to go to see the oracle.
Like, you want to go
and get a prediction,
this is where you would go.
And walking into
the Temple of Apollo
back in the day
in ancient Greece,
I'm wondering if they knew a
thing or two about game theory.
So there are three
inscriptions above the temple.
The first one is
know thyself, right?
Know your own hand.
Know your own distribution.
The second is nothing in excess.
Play with balance.
So know thyself,
nothing in excess.
And the last one is make a
pledge and mischief is nigh.
Yeah, it's really a real
stretch to make that one work,
so we'll just leave
it at mischief.
Mischief can sometimes be good.
So let me be very clear
on how important I
think this concept of
knowing your own hand,
knowing where you are in
your own distribution is.
I think you should not think
about anything else in poker
until you have bought and paid
for a house by knowing where
you are in your
own distribution,
in shaping it to be balanced.
Don't think about anything else.
Everything else is
just window dressing
compared to this concept.
So here we are again.
So we're going to go
through this hand, the one
that I told you about at
the beginning of the talk,
and we're going to try
to read our own hand.
So again, we're playing
against this player who's
better than us,
some stuff happens,
what do we do on the river?
How do we think about that from
a game theoretic perspective?
So there are kind
of three ways again
that I alluded to
in the beginning
that people might
think about it, right?
So the first one is my
hand versus your hand, OK?
Well, I have aces.
What do I think he has?
King queen?
King 10?
Maybe he has queen 10?
Maybe he's bluffing?
Maybe he has queen nine?
What is his most likely hand?
And probably as most
of you have already
realized-- so Kevin told me
that you'd all played at least
100 tournaments so
far, I'm guessing
some a lot more-- it's
really hard to put someone
on a particular hand,
not particularly useful.
So the next thing
you might try to do
is my hand versus
your distribution.
How are my aces doing
against all the hands
that you might have given
the actions you've taken?
I can't really put
you on one hand,
but I can look at
your actions and see
what sort of distribution
they might suggest.
And then the last one
is my distribution
versus your distribution.
And this is I can
look at your actions
and I can look at
my actions, and I
can try to shape my actions
such that they maximally
exploit your actions.
So it's not so much about
what I'm doing with my aces.
It's about what I'm doing with
all the hands that I'd have,
where I just happen
to have aces here.
And this is the style that's
most complimentary to game
theory.
So again, we're on this river
and with pot odds with my aces
I might be thinking, am I good
at least a third of the time
here?
But if I'm doing that
I'm trying to do magic,
because I'm trying to figure
out exactly what he has.
And I don't think we
need to do that here.
Right?
What I want to be thinking
is, well, how much of the time
do I need to call
to make my opponent
indifferent to bluffing?
Any guesses?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Like 40% of the time?
MATT HAWRILENKO: Yeah.
So something like
1 over 1 plus s.
So how do we get there?
So this is the slide--
guys, if you pay attention
to one slide this
whole talk, this
is the slide to
pay attention to.
This is the slide where we
map the ace, king, queen
game to actual poker.
So the whole idea of poker
from a game theory perspective
is we're going to try
to make bluffing zero
EV for our opponents.
So we're going to call with
the proportion of our hands.
We're going to make
bluffing zero EV.
So in real poker, games
that allow raising,
that means we could
potentially be raising.
So we want to be
continuing 1 over 1 plus s
at the time, at least
calling, pondering arrays.
So what do we see?
So if this is the
ace, king, queen game,
we're going to map it
to real poker this way.
This is like our 99th percentile
hand, the very best hand we
can have in this spot, right?
So on that board there were
two kings on the board,
so a 99th percentile hand would
be like quad kings, right?
Would be four of a kind.
This is our worst hand, the
very worst hand we could have
in this spot, I don't know.
A four deuce.
And so what we're
going to do-- so again,
these are the hands that are
the very best at showdown,
very high EV.
Very worst at
showdown, very low EV.
So we're going to be
calling or raising 1 over 1
plus s of the time.
So the question is going to be,
what is our distribution here?
What is 1 over 1 plus s?
Our bluffed value ratio
is going to be s over 1
plus s of our
worst hands, right?
These are the hands that gain
the most value by bluffing,
right?
The ones that are going to
do the worst at showdown.
Well, not for us in this spot.
I'm going to talk
about that later.
Let's leave that for a second.
But those are the hands that
my opponent should be bluffing,
right?
So if we think about
our value betting range,
I might have a different
value betting range than you.
And that has implications
for how we play differently
than each other.
So the wider my
value betting range
is, the more hands I
need to be bluffing.
As this region expands,
this region expands.
So if my opponent is
value betting more hands,
they should also
be bluffing more.
So when you see some of the
very best no-limit players
play these guys who are just
complete animals-- you're like,
how are they
bluffing that there?
How are they calling that there?
How are they making
this value bet so thin?
This how they do it, right?
If they're value betting a lot,
they're also bluffing a lot.
So you have to call them more.
So the more they bluff, the
more they have to value bet.
This is one of the places
where a lot of beginners
just get way, way out of
whack, because bluffing is--
it starts scary and
then it gets sexy,
and then it gets
something in between.
So the whole idea, don't
let this get out of whack.
And again, the larger amount
that my opponent bets,
the less frequently
I have to call.
The less they bet, the more
frequently I have to call.
So we're about to our own hand.
Let's keep these couple
of things in mind.
So again, I think
reading your own hand is
the most important
skill in poker,
and it's because what you do
with part of your distribution
shapes what you do
with the rest of it.
And so what we're about to do
is we're going to go through
and we're going to sort
of make some frequency
updates on each street.
So we're going to
do two updates.
We're going to sort of update
what our hands might be given
the cards that have come out.
So there's a card
removal effect, right?
If an ace comes out,
I'm a lot less likely
to have a pair of aces because
there are fewer combinations.
And then we're also going
to account for the actions
that we take.
So let's just do it.
It'll be clear.
So, OK.
So I've opened two
off the button.
So here's some kind
of reasonable range
for opening two off the button.
So we've gotten rid of all
the hands that aren't here.
This is what I might
have right now, OK?
So you don't really
need to pay attention
to the specifics here, but
flop comes, king, jack, eight.
So now I'm going to
update for card removal.
So all the hands in
orange are the frequencies
that have changed, right?
So eights, I could
have had six of them
before the flop came, but
now that there's an eight,
I only have three
of them, et cetera.
So our total combination
down the bottom
here has gone down, right?
So now what happens?
Well, they check, I bet.
So what hands am I betting
here when my opponent checks?
Well, I'm getting
rid of some of them.
I don't know if they're
the right ones or not,
but I'm getting rid of some
pairs, some bottom pairs,
some gut shots.
I might not be betting
those here, right?
So the hands in white are all
the hands I'm still betting.
And again, our frequency
is coming down.
Our distribution is narrowing.
So the turn comes.
It's a five.
We get rid of some hands
with fives in them.
I bet 2/3 of the pot.
So we get rid of all the hands
in this distribution where
I'm not betting 2/3 of the pot.
And really quickly,
when you're thinking
about reading your
own hand-- and I'm
going to say that the most
important time to be doing
it is probably off the table--
when you're thinking about it,
you should be really thinking
about every street, OK?
So OK.
So these are the hands
that I'm value betting.
Turns out I'm value betting
about 94 combinations here.
How's my proportion of bluffs?
So I'm value betting
94 combinations.
I have a total of 120.
So that leaves what?
26 hands.
So how often should
I be bluffing?
Or-- hm.
96.
I'm value betting 96
leaving 24 bluff hands.
So how often should
I be bluffing?
OK, so 96 times-- what's that?
Is it like 1 over 1 plus s, s
over 1 plus s, s over 1 plus s?
So times 0.4-- that's
the amount I'm betting,
I'm betting 40% of the
pot-- times 1 plus 0.4.
So 96 times 0.4.
Yeah.
96 times 0.4 over 1.4.
All right.
So I should be bluffing
about 27 hands.
What do I have?
16, 24?
Huh.
Did pretty well.
I'm happy with that.
Pretty good shape.
I don't know.
I don't know about
all the other actions.
We can argue about what
I'm checking behind,
but we don't want
to over think it.
So generally speaking, I want to
be checking in on each street.
Like, ooh.
Am I balanced here in the way
that I should be balanced?
So the river comes a king, and
now we have fewer combinations.
So what do I do with my aces?
So again, s, the bet
size, he bets $1,080,000
into a $720,000 chip pot.
So s is 1.5.
I should be calling
1.5 over 2.5, 40%.
That's 40% of hands
that beat a bluff.
So what does that look like?
So if we're thinking
about our calling region,
what I've done here is I've
just sort of taken all my hands
and I've ranked them, and so
kings represent my top 1%, king
jack.
Now we're at 9%.
This is like the cumulative
sort of frequency distribution
with my hands ranked.
And I'm saying here
in this distribution,
queen jack is the worst hand
that still beats a bluff.
We can argue about
that, but rough guess.
So first nothing in excess,
calling 1 over 1 plus
s of a time.
Where are we?
Ooh.
This is surprising to me.
This felt like a
tough decision, right?
So we're actually at the
62nd percentile here.
So one question is, so from
this, what should I be doing?
Should I be calling or folding?
Folding.
Yeah.
So it looks like I'm
calling with my king queen.
I might be folding
king 10 maybe.
We can talk about
that a little bit.
But aces seem like a
pretty clear fold here.
Suppose my opponent thinks that
I'll fold good hands like aces,
and so he's like, mm.
I'm going to bluff
90% of the time here.
Is he exploiting me?
Seeing head shakes.
He's not exploiting me, right?
So why not?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Because
you win on his bluff.
Such a big question at the
time, it makes up for the pot
that you're losing.
MATT HAWRILENKO: Yeah.
My distribution is really
strong here, right?
Of the hands that beat a bluff,
like half of them have trips.
That's crazy to me.
So no.
So he's not exploiting
me, but we will talk
about exploitation in a minute.
So we solved it, right?
So we fold aces.
We even fold king 10.
So one question
is, do we actually
want to have a
distribution in the spot
where we have to fold trips?
And if that feels kind of
bad, well, two possibilities.
One it just feels
bad, or two, it
might mean we sort of
screwed up on the way here.
It's not the worst.
It's not a four flush board.
There are no straights
on it, right?
Some folding trips here,
that feels kind of bad.
So what might that mean?
A couple of things, right?
So one thing we could
do is I probably
want a distribution where
I don't have to fold it.
And again, it depends a
little bit on bet size,
but this is a pretty
reasonable rule of thumb
when you're thinking
about shaping
your play off the table.
So one thing that we can
do, we can add some hands
in from earlier.
Ooh, maybe I should have
played the turn a little bit
differently.
Maybe I should have
played preflop,
maybe I should have played
some more hands, right?
So we can start to
expand our range.
Right?
Now we're calling with
most all of our kings.
We can actually construct
a distribution where
we have to call it aces, right?
If we're playing way
more hands and if we're
value betting way more hands
throughout, all of a sudden
our distribution
is wider, right?
And now I should be in the
same spot with the same hand
and do something differently
because my strategy to get here
was different.
And again, that's the same idea.
You see these
really good players
making these crazily thin
value bets, and this is why.
They're bluffing a lot
so they value bet a lot.
The main idea that I
want you to take away,
if we sort of think
of a principle,
if I find myself on the river
and I have more medium strength
hands, I have to call more
with medium strength hands,
otherwise I can get exploited.
Suppose we were deeper and
our opponent bets into us,
and we have a bunch more chips.
Which hands should we be bluff
raising from this distribution?
So most the time, if I'm
just straight bluffing,
I want to be bluffing with the
very bottom of my distribution
because that's the
part the gains the most
when my opponent folds.
If I'm bluff raising,
it's a little different.
If I'm bluff raising, I
want to think about, OK,
so what is the set of
hands I would fold?
What are the very best hands
in that set that I would fold?
And I may as well
choose those, right?
Because it seems like those
hands have more value, so
if I'm going to
fold them anyway,
it's a dominated
strategy to bluff raise
with hands that are
weaker than that, right?
So if I'm bluff raising,
it should be really
with the very best hands
that I would otherwise
fold, not with the very
bottom of my distribution.
So what do we see here?
So first off, we want to check
for balance on all streets.
That's the big
thing we take away.
We can argue about little
bits of distributions,
but really, we're not solving
to the second decimal point
here, right?
Second, we can look
at this board all day.
We can look at this king jack
eight five king board all day.
Unfortunately, that's not
going to be the board that
comes every time, and if we
just look at this board all day,
we're going to start to overfit
our strategy a little bit
to this board.
So what I suggest you focus on
is fixing the glaring errors,
and there will be
glaring errors, places
where your distribution
is way, way imbalanced.
I still find glaring
errors when I play poker,
and I've been trying to do
this for a little while now.
Another thought which is not
quite so obvious from what I've
said so far is, you don't
want to needlessly bifurcate
your distribution.
How do you bifurcate
your distribution?
Well, suppose preflop,
I raise some amount
with some set of hands
and in a different amount
with a different set of hands.
Ooh, right?
All of a sudden I started off
here with 310 combinations,
and I got down to, I don't
know, 60 or something.
But now all of a sudden, I'm
starting off with half that.
I'm starting off with 155, in
this game tree gets smaller
really, really quickly.
So I'm not saying don't do it.
But I'm saying if you do it,
A, have a really good reason
for doing it.
B, be really careful.
Be really careful of
betting different amounts
with different hand types.
I basically don't.
I will bet different
amounts based
on the texture of the board.
So if boards are
more [? drawy ?]
I might tend to make my
bet sizes larger earlier.
But I won't bet different
amounts with different hand
types because I think it the
possible gain is so small
and the possible loss is so big.
And the last thing that I
found pretty cool about this
was when I started
really, really spending
time trying to read
my own hand, I'd
start to find these
consistent situations where
I would get really imbalanced.
And then when you want to
start to think about moving on
to exploitive play
after you have paid off
a house with your
poker winnings,
you want to maybe identify those
spots in your own opponents,
right?
If you're getting
imbalanced there,
other people probably are
too, so be ready for that.
So what do I want to say here?
So I guess we've ignored a
few assumptions of this model,
right?
The biggest assumption in a toy
game like the ace king queen
game or the Coin Flip
Clairvoyance game
is that distributions
are symmetric.
If I'm applying the ace
king queen game to my river
situation here, I'm
implicitly assuming
that my opponents
and I essentially
have an equivalent distribution
of aces, kings, and queens.
That's not always true in poker.
So generally I'd say that this
sort this mapping is actually
fairly robust, but
at the same time,
you have to be
aware of situations
where your distributions
aren't symmetric, right?
Like if you raise under the
gun at a ten handed table
and the big blind
calls, your distribution
is way, way stronger.
It's not symmetric.
So you're going to have a
different set of actions.
However, as you progress
throughout the hand,
distributions sort of tend to
become more and more symmetric.
So generally speaking, it's
a model with some assumptions
which are meh.
But in my experience,
it holds pretty well.
So another thing I
haven't talked about today
is I haven't told you which
hands to value bet, right?
So I've told you the
calling proportion,
bluffing proportion.
I haven't said anything about,
how do you choose what to bet?
And there are game theory
games that can kind of give you
insight into that.
You can get insight into that
from Bill and Jared's book.
But I think that
what's most important
here is reading your own
hand is the thing that I
think can integrate
into everybody's game.
Whatever hands you currently
value bet, it can work for you.
Right?
And it can sort of work equally
well for the right player
as it can for the
very loose player.
So the reason I've decided
to talk about the reading
your own hand approach is this
is a very flexible approach
that can work for a lot of
people in a lot of situations.
And, you know, as you
get better and you
start to play more and more
hands-- or fewer and fewer,
depending where you
fall on the spectrum--
but generally as you start to
play more and more hands, what
you're doing here, thinking
from sort of like this game
theoretic perspective
is you're moving
towards hands that are closer to
threshold hands, closer to zero
easy.
So adding in the nth hand
has a much smaller effect
than adding in that,
like, fifth hand, right?
Or if you think about all the
good hands in poker, right?
So you're always going
to play your jacks,
you're always going to
play your 10s, right?
Adding in that nine six suited
has a much smaller impact
on your EV than adding in the
10s, the nines, the eights.
Yeah, that's all I
want to say there.
So in the last few minutes
I'm going to talk really
briefly about exploitive play.
So exploitive play.
So if we're looking at the top,
our best hand's at showdown,
our worst hand's at showdown.
And this is about where our
value betting threshold is.
The way to exploit from a
game theoretic perspective
isn't to say, ah, I
know he's bluffing!
I call a blind!
Although apparently that can
work pretty well sometimes.
The way you do it is you
expand to the margins.
So if normally I'm value
betting here and my opponent--
or normally I'm calling
here and my opponent bluffs
way too much, I might expand
to the marginal calls.
That's one thing I might do.
If they don't
value bet enough, I
might contract the
marginal calls, right?
But again, the ones that
are very close to zero EV,
I'm never making
the big fold here.
If they fold too
much, I might expand
to the marginal
bluffs a little bit
and contract the marginal
bets a little bit.
If they call too much, I'm going
to expand the marginal bets
and contract the
marginal bluffs.
So what that means
is you get away
from, I think he's bluffing 80%
of the time in this situation,
to-- in this exact
situation, and I'm
going to catch him-- to, hm.
This person seems
a little bluffy,
so I'm going to
shape my distribution
just a little bit around that.
OK.
So the other idea
about exploitive play
is as your read grows stronger,
as you have more confidence,
you can expand to
the margins, right?
So a little read, you
move the margins a little.
Big read, you move
the margins more.
For example, well, OK.
So with our example hand, we
have a margin right about here,
but we can start
to move it wider
as our read grow stronger that
our opponent might be bluffing.
But again, we don't
want to move it
wider with just the hand that I
happen to be holding right now.
We need to be thinking,
how strong is it,
and how wide am I
comfortable moving it?
Yeah.
So if we're thinking
about exploiting
with my sort of, like,
shamefully exploitive hand,
what did I do?
Well, it wasn't quite a 1
over 1 plus s situation.
We're in this
situation where I'm
going to be shoving in the top
hands and folding the worst.
So if my margin was here, if
my margin was, I don't know,
eight six suited or
something, maybe I'd
go, like, eight five suited.
Maybe I'd go king deuce off
suit, something like that.
Instead what I did
was I went all the way
to the very bottom
of my distribution
and got suitably punished.
Yeah.
So however confident you
think you are in your read,
you are probably
overestimating it.
So, yeah.
That's where I was.
One other thought
here before I wrap up,
and that's this idea of
advanced exploitive play,
and this is fun.
So we think about
expanding the margins.
We think, oh, in this
spot he's bluffing.
I should call more.
But now if you start to make
slightly more subtle reads,
this is an opponent who bluffs
a little too much on the river,
I could punish him on
the river by calling,
or this is an opponent who
folds too much on the river.
I could punish them,
or I could punish her
by betting the river.
But they're going
to get that feedback
pretty soon if you're just
starting to hammer every river.
Another thing you
can do is you can
make the pot a little
bit bigger, right?
So don't forget about this.
This is the pot.
If you start making this
bigger on earlier streets,
maybe against this
particular player,
I raise a little
bit more preflop.
I bet a little bit
more on the flop.
Right?
The pot's bigger on the turn,
so now I'm betting on the turn.
And now with the river I
take all my normal actions
except I know that I'm
winning a few too many pots
because they're
folding too much,
and now the few too many
parts that I'm winning
are proportionally larger.
So this is this idea of
we can exploit downstream.
We can anticipate
where they're weak.
We cannot change our play in
that spot and tip them off,
but we can change it earlier.
So to wrap up, so you
want to know yourself.
You want know your
own hand, right?
That's the first key.
The second key is
to keep it balanced,
and you want to
exploit the margins.
And so as we think
about Cepheus,
as we think about
these algorithms coming
and exploiting players, so even
in 20 years, computing power--
oh, what's that?
Like 1,000 times
greater or something?
Is that right?
Wrong?
AUDIENCE: Sounds all right.
MATT HAWRILENKO: Depending.
Depending if you believe
Moore's law, I guess.
OK.
So even then, even when more
poker games are tractable,
you're going to need toy
games to draw insights
on what's going on.
As these strategies come out
of the black boxes, if you
hope to grasp them, if you
hope to hold onto them,
you need these kind
of insights to be
able to have some scaffolding
to start to put them on.
So I think I'm done, but if I
were to summarize this talk one
way, don't be this guy.
Be this guy.
OK, we're done.
Any questions?
Ooh, wait.
AUDIENCE: So if you're doing,
like, Nash equilibrium, well,
that guarantees
you a positive EV.
But [INAUDIBLE]
that's always enough.
Like, if you're in tournament
having a positive EV,
your chips will grow a
little but [? maybe blinds ?]
are growing faster.
Is that an [INAUDIBLE]
Nash equilibrium strategy,
or do you have to
deviate if you want
a higher variance [INAUDIBLE]?
MATT HAWRILENKO: Yeah,
so good question.
So the question-- and tell me--
let me make sure we answer it--
the question is, OK, well, you
can try to play an equilibrium
strategy and that's fine.
But if you're exploiting,
you're winning more.
And so if you're
playing in tournaments
or these situations,
you really need
to exploit to win more money.
Is that kind of-- yeah?
So yeah.
That idea has been
around for a long time,
and I think that
that idea is driven
by people not really knowing
just how strong game theory
strategies might be, and just
how strong sort of like, OK.
So what is a Nash
equilibria here?
When you're playing
a Nash equilibria,
the idea is that your opponents
are going to impale themselves
on their own
mistakes, and you're
trying to make as few
mistakes as possible.
And how big is that, right?
It's kind of an
empirical question.
In my experience, it
can be a lot bigger
than most people think.
Because when you
start exploiting,
you start making mistakes.
And you start sort of
getting impaled a little bit
on your own mistakes too.
And my guess is for most
of us, for 99% of us,
we're going to make a lot more
mistakes than we think we do.
So we think we're exploiting.
At the same time we're
getting exploited.
So actually, thinking about
that is an empirical question,
right?
Like, how do human players
do right now against Cepheus?
My guess is not very well.
In fact, my guess
is that they're
losing more than
the top players,
the top human
players are winning
from other human players.
So that was certainly kind of
my experience a few years ago.
So it's one of these things
where you'd see it, right?
Like I think-- I don't know.
I feel like I saw some stat
where Cepheus was beating
really good professionals
for four bets per hundred
hands, which is a lot.
Which is a lot.
Like, most top players are
winning less than half of that.
So Nash equilibria, yeah.
Pretty darn good.
Maybe one day when human
players are better,
you need to start
exploiting more.
I don't think we're
anywhere close.
Other questions?
Anything else?
All right, I guess we're done.
Thanks guys.
I'll stick around for a little
bit if anyone wants to chat.
[APPLAUSE]